hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to my game engine series
day 4 of game engine series week here
today and today we're going to be doing
some
pretty exciting work we're going to be
adding serialization and deserialization
to hazel meaning that we can actually
by the end of today save our scenes out
into a file and also load them
so it's gonna be pretty exciting because
at the moment we're creating our entire
scene through code and if we do
anything if we actually create anything
with hazel or with hazelnut which we're
able to do now
using all the new ui that we've added
such as the items here component ui all
of that stuff
from the previous episode which i will
link up there now that we can do all
that stuff it would be really nice to be
able to save that to a file so that we
can save our work because
not saving our work obviously is is
really really annoying
so that is what we're going to be doing
today let's dive right into the code
we've got a lot of stuff
that we need to do um
let's take a look at it okay so as
always i've got like a
you know i've got the code over here and
i want to mention that for this episode
even though i feel like
some people probably won't like this too
much i am actually going to be copying
and pasting code that i've already
written
the reason is that the actual serializer
code that i've
written is like 250 lines that file so i
don't want to type it all out in front
of you
i will incrementally copy and paste it
and then explain it as well so that you
make the so that it makes sense to you
but a lot of it is just normal
kind of boring civilization code that we
just need to get through every field
of like the camera class for example and
actually serialize it so hopefully like
the important stuff will still be
explained and it will make sense
so i guess the first question is how are
we going to serialize it
uh well there's two different i've
talked about this before but there's two
different ways to serialize
there's the kind of text format that we
want to use for production so when we're
actually working on the
on like a game or a project using
hazelnut we want to serialize our scene
into a text file
the reason we don't want to use binary
for that and we want to use text for
that is because we want it to be human
readable
and possibly more importantly human
mergeable meaning that if two people
work on that same kind of scene file
and they're both likely to say add one
entity each we want to easily be able to
merge that together just using like a
get like merge tool or something like
that
right we don't want to actually have to
you know create some weird binary tool
that's going to map
like manually you know merge all those
bytes together
that's awful we don't want to do
anything like that we just want to have
normal
text file format and we specifically
i've i've i've chosen yaml for our text
file format
because it's really really easy to read
and more importantly really easy
to merge so if you actually go to the
yaml website
it's entirely written in yaml this is
all yaml compliant where you see all the
text here
and as you can see it's really easy to
read json on the other hand
is not that easy to read and it's a lot
harder to merge
because any time i've had to merge json
in the past
there's always like some curly bracket
that i missed or something is misaligned
and because of that it just becomes
really really super annoying
um because well you know something's
gone wrong and now i have to go back and
trace all of my
it's a disaster this is really easy
there's no weird brackets here anywhere
you can see that we have like you know
um key and value pairs like in a map
we've also got arrays which adopt points
which is just so easy to read so i
really really do like yaml
and that's the format that we're going
to use and it's used by unity as well so
it's
obviously not something that's very
obscure now as
always i've created a little fork of
yaml cpp which is the library we're
going to use for this
i'm not too concerned about performance
here because this is just for like
loading and saving scene files and
possibly
any other kind of production like data
right this is not something that we kind
of use
for um this is not something that we
kind of use for
something serious like runtime code
where like you know we want it to be
like as fast as possible and
we care about performance now this is
saving loading scenes right so not too
concerned about performance here
um there might be a faster yammer
library out there i've been using this
one for a while in hazel dev
and it's fast enough i feel and it's
it's easy to use and it's great
and more importantly it doesn't have any
dependencies really
uh it's all kind of like self-contained
in here because what i did notice was i
think i used another
yaml library and it like you know
included
parts of boost and other libraries and
that's just that's just too much like i
don't want any of that there's so much
extra stuff on it's so heavy
i don't really care for that so instead
i'm gonna be using um
this one here so i've just added a
pre-make file to
it just like i've done with imgui this
is the pre-mag file it's
super simple i mean it's very
straightforward to compile this you just
need to
you know include the cpp files for
compilation i've also included the
header files
so they're part of the project and then
finally include as an include directory
and that's
it it's that simple uh the rest is
literally copied from the i am gui
premake file so to add this as a sub
module as
always we just have to go to like uh
you know the the directory right
um i'll open a command prompt here and
i'm just going to type in git sub module
add uh that's the um
link to the sub module and then we want
to add it to uh
hazel i think slash vendor
now this is another thing that um you
might want to think about do we want
this to be inside hazel or hazelnut
well whilst yaml is predominantly going
to be probably used by just hazelnut
most of the time i still want to make it
possible to serialize into yaml for
runtime
the reason is that is potentially going
to be really easy for debugging
and it's also going to because remember
hazel is not just a game engine it can
just be a
anything engine really can be used for a
lot of different applications
uh you know if we're creating a new
application that isn't hazelnut we
probably want to support yaml
serialization and deserialization
but more importantly what if we just
want to put together a little graphics
demo
and we want it to be really easy for a
person to modify which model file it
loads for
for example well if we just have like a
little model viewer app or something
some kind of weird sandbox right
that opens a yaml file someone could
just open the yaml file inside notepad
or
visual studio code and change the path
to be something else so that might be
something that we want to support like
we could ultimately use the yaml file as
almost a configuration file
that's human editable without having to
like open hazelnut
and that could be useful obviously for a
number of cases so that's why i want to
make this part of poor
cork hazel core hazel
um instead of being part of hazelnut
just because i think that it
definitely has a wider use case so i
think that's the syntax github module
add
that and then the path which is
hazelvendor
hopefully i'm right um
i think it's actually the other way
around maybe
okay what have i done hazel vender and
then i might have to do that
yep because that's the actual clone
directory my
bad okay there we go so it's done it's
now a git module it's now
in here fantastic now what do we have to
do to actually
uh get it to be part of our pre-make
file not much
i mean honestly all we have to do is
make sure that we have an include
directory for it which is actually in
the other
um we'll add that in a minute but that's
actually in the uh pre-make file it's in
the solution directory
yaml underscore will have to go with cpp
because it can't be a dash
in this case um files to
there's nothing changes here links we're
going to link obviously
yaml cpp this time with a dash
and i think that's really all we have to
do here
oh and we want to add it as an include
drop we've done directory my bad okay so
back here we'll open the printmake file
this part of the
root directory the solution one that
actually sets up the workspace and we'll
have to add
um yaml underscore cpp here which is
just
vendor yaml cpp and it's also got an
include directory
and then finally over here so that it
actually shows up as a project under our
dependencies
filter here we want to have hazel vendor
and yaml cpp
i think that is it and this will
obviously include the actual pre-make
script
um i think that's it i'm not sure i'm
not referring to my diff for this so
hopefully this is correct let's go
scripts let's rerun this script
and then if we reload this not only
should we have
uh yaml cpp up here which we can now
right click and build
we should also have
excuse me we should also have um it
linked to
hazel which is great so let's just give
that a bill to make sure everything
works i mean it's not we're not using
the code yet
and we can actually start on this
serializer so how do we write a
serializer
well i am the way that i like to do this
is of course
as as this entire series is completely
just my preference
you can write your own engine that's
what this series is here for just to
show you how
one might approach writing an engine um
i don't like to add serializers to the
actual
like class that is being serialized so
pretty i mean
mostly this this is going to be
serializing just the same class
everything that we need is going to be
inside scene
but i don't want to add a little
serialized function
the reason is i picture serialization as
an external thing
and i like to separate it out into an
external serializer class that's usually
how i do things it depends on the size
and the scope of serialization
you can imagine the scene is quite
complex right it's quite complicated to
serialize it's not that straightforward
and because it's so complicated to
serialize we might want to separate it
out into a new file
so that it's actually just you know
clean and when we're actually you know
caring about the runtime behavior of our
scene which is also going to be quite
large
in the future i don't want to have to be
you know stumbling through
so much serialization code so because of
that i'm going to under scene
make a new item here and it's going to
be a scene serializer
so i'm going to do scene serializer now
this is going to support obviously both
serialization and deserialization so
we'll add
that like that will include the pch as
well as the
scene serializer file like that
namespace hazel as always and then over
here we can start on
actually implementing our seed
serializer so i'll include
scene because obviously it needs that
that's what it's going to be serializing
and then we're going to have a pretty
simple straightforward class here
that much like our pattern of taking in
inside the scene hierarchy um is uh how
we take in like a context in the scene
hierarchy panel we have like a context
which is an actual
scene that we can set over here the same
way we're going to be
constructing a scene serializer that
takes in a scene right so this will be
scene serializer and then we'll do
const uh ref scene because we don't need
to
copy and increment the ref count here um
construct scene scene right that's the
thing that we're serializing
and of course it's going to store it as
a member and that's where we're going to
copy it
and increment the ref count all right
and now we just provide some functions
so serialize to a file
so const std string
file path and then serialize and we'll
call it serialized runtime so this is
the
this is the part of the serializer
that's going to serialize into binary
instead of yaml
whereas this will basically serialize
kind of
i don't know you could call this
serialized text serialized binary
um but i'm just going to kind of call it
like this maybe for now
um deserialize uh to deserialize and
decelerate runtime again
both are going to take in file paths
that's the entire api so the idea
is this is a very very light stack kind
of
constructable class here that we provide
a context with it stores that context
and then you can call
these functions um however you like so
you could
you could store it you don't have to
store it you can just you know
instantiate a new instance of this class
really easily really quickly
and then just call a relevant function
on it and that way like you know you
don't have to have some kind of weird
static floating thing
that um you know like a static function
somewhere that's floating that has to
you know take in a scene and then a file
path and all that stuff it's really
quite simple to work with
and i do really like this api okay great
so now let's um
[Music]
create the method implementations and
specifically what i'm going to do
here is uh immediately for all this to
serialize stuff
just add a core asset um just add a core
assert here that says
um that's well i'll just record that
false and just add a little comment that
says not implemented
and in fact i'm one of these i'm going
to change the decentralization to be
boolean so i might do that i don't know
if i'll do that with serialized just yet
but
um because obviously what this does is
it deserializes
into this scene that you provide it with
so in other words if you were learning a
blank scene you would make a new scene
object yourself
and then pass it in here this is also
nice because it means that the
deserialized function doesn't also have
the job and the responsibility of
allocating memory for a scene
that can be done externally then you
just give it the ref and it will
deserialize into that existing scene
um which in in in this case if you were
learning a blank one it would just be
like a new scene that you've just
created
fresh empty and then you pass it into
the deserialize function
or rather into the serializer and then
you call the deserialize function on
that
now um so let's return false here for
now because it's not implemented
so this realize runtime and then
serialize runtime as well
we'll just make sure that we assert
there just in case they're called so
that we know
that this is not implemented yet okay
cool
so with the serializer with a
constructor all we need to do is set the
scene
so we've got the context now and then
finally we can think about
serializing everything so we'll include
our yaml
file here so uh yaml cpp yaml just like
that
now i i forgot i forget our convention i
think
yeah i think we've we've said that um
[Music]
i guess if it's outside of our current
project we use
angular brackets like that so i guess
this should appear like this
because i wasn't sure if we wanted it to
be like that if it's outside of our
project or outside of the whole solution
because obviously this source code
is in fact all available to us um inside
this yaml
cpp um project okay anyway we've
included
uh yaml so now we need to serialize so
as i mentioned i'm going to be copying
and pasting some stuff because it's
going to be way too long
the way that i've implemented this is
basically uh like this let's copy the
first little bit here um and
i will explain it
so two quick things um let's go back to
the scene class
we need to add the serializer as a
friend because obviously we need to
allow access to serializer to go into
our deepest darkest secrets which are
like the registry itself and all of that
stuff since it needs to actually
serialize us
um and then also uh we might need to
include some other stuff but we'll see
okay so what does this do well it's
really simple again this whole process
is so simple right
we create a yaml emitter this is using
the yaml cpp library
we begin a map because this whole file
is really going to be a map right
and then i have a key value here which
is a scene name now we're not storing a
scene name
now as far as i'm aware probably
something we want to do
so i've just put like name goes here
kind of here
so so this this is going to be like the
scene name
um so we might even call it something
like un named
sim okay or maybe like untitled
because it's a bit shorter okay so this
is where it would go that's our key in
value
i like to actually write key values like
this so you can just keep kind of
outputting stuff into there
so this is the key this is the value
great with entities
instead of having the value be like a
normal thing in fact i might also
collapse this
instead of the value being a normal
thing the value is actually a sequence
right
so a sequence is essentially like an
array
um i think it actually is an array and
we'll look at what this looks like in a
minute obviously when we actually
serialize it
but we begin a sequence and now we go
through every entity
and if it's valid we serialize it
uh then we end the sequence we end that
array we end the map which is like the
whole kind of file right so entities is
the key
the value is the array uh and then we
just output it into the
file using of stream right so uh
really really simple um i guess i'll
just include f stream
i'm not sure if we need to we might
excuse me we might be
including it um from some other uh
places as well
so serialized entity this can just be a
static function doesn't really need to
be
um a member so we'll do static
void serialize entity um we'll take in a
yaml emitter
right because obviously this is like our
output here um
and then uh we'll take in the entity
that we're trying to serialize and now
obviously this function works
so how do we serialize an entity well
let's begin really simply and then we'll
kind of run this and
you'll see how it changes so this is the
first thing that i did
entities should have goods right or
uuids right universally unique
identifiers the reason is that um
there are a lot of reasons why we want
to have like a proper id
um and this isn't like uh like i'm not
going to get into it now
but essentially we need and we need to
have a proper id per entity so that we
can properly identify it
and it should be like a globally unique
asterisk
id because like it's possible that these
ids get created like
at you know across different like
computers and essentially that we don't
want like a global authority handing out
incrementing ids we want them to be
random um because that way they can get
created uh
wherever whenever and it's obviously
extremely unlikely that it will conflict
with an existing entity
we don't have that yet so that's why we
have this random string of numbers here
to do entity id goes here okay and as
mentioned i worked
all this stuff out during the live
stream so that's basically so we begin a
map called
entity that means that we also have to
end the map so i like to add a comment
here
specify specifying which map
specifically
um it's affecting so that way when we
begin and i don't know why i didn't do
that
it should be like that i guess because a
long line but whatever so we have the
entity id now
and then what we're gonna do is actually
uh
i guess have um because we've we've
begun a map now so the
entity is going to be equal to this
which is just like the id i could have
called this id but
entity just makes it a little bit more
readable and then we have to go through
everything and serialize everything
so as an example let's serialize
something really simple first the tag
component
so let's include components because we
need to be aware of all of them
so if we have a tag component which
obviously we should
but i've just got an if statement here
might as well for safety
then we will uh grab our tag component
key
right so this is like basically saying
hey this is a tag component
and then i begin a map which stores
everything the attack i'm printing it
now in this case the tag component is
just a tag so i could have just you know
essentially made this code look like
that right
tag component equals tag right but for
um consistency's sake because this i'm
trying to keep this consistent with
other components obviously that will
have more than one like
uh data field to serialize i've done it
a little bit differently okay
um well at least i've done it this way
even though for this example might be
overkill
and that's our tag component right and
then so what i'll do is obviously end
the map which i should have done here
uh and i think that's it so that this is
a very very simple example of
just serializing a single component from
an entity
but based on this you should be able to
implement the rest yourselves obviously
i'll do it in this episode as well
because i have to but if you want a
little bit of an exercise
obviously feel free to just do the stuff
there's always stuff flying around
why anyway sorry
um feel free to take this as an exercise
and opportunity to maybe uh do some of
your own programming if you want and
implement the rest of these because
there are certain things that are
more complicated to serialize that we
will have to do
right um
but that's going to be fine like i uh
you know like for example things like um
you know vec fours or vec3s or the glm
math types we obviously need to provide
custom code to serialize that
because yaml doesn't know yeah yeah more
cpp the library doesn't know how to
serialize that stuff but we'll get
through that that's it
this is as simple as it is so let's see
what we end up with with this kind of
yaml code
um how do we use this well i said it was
really simple right so all we have to do
is inside editor layer
let's include scene uh what is it hazel
scene slash scene serializer right
we'll make our scene using simple source
code which is what we're currently doing
um and then maybe like at the bottom
i'll do scene serializer serializer
right which takes in our scene which is
our active scene i believe
and then it just does serialize it dot
serialize and then let's go to assets
scenes uh example dot
hazel okay that's it
let's run this code and we'll see what
we get
and it's already an error
um let's go back here and return false
dc realize we are actually going to
implement today so
um not too fast about that okay so
nothing
appears to be different but obviously
now what we should have is inside
hazelnut we should have a little file
um inside the hazelnut directory i
should say called uh
sorry easter bean assets um
[Music]
why isn't it here asset scenes example
we might need to actually create the
directories ourselves um
i've forgotten how to do that
uh let's see what's happening here
um yeah so it definitely should be
it should definitely should be written
let's just test this out quickly
let's add a folder called scenes and see
if that works
uh yeah
there it is all right so we'll we'll
need to add some flags probably to the
out of stream so that creates all the
directories for us but we will do that a
bit later so we have example.hazel and
if we double click on it this is what
our yaml file looks like so we have
scene
untitled right we could probably get
yaml to add a little comment at the top
as well that specifies like what kind of
file it is we can do that if we want um
but then we have the list of entities
here the array
so we have uh the fcid and then a list
of components so we have tag component
and then the tag is camera b and we have
camera a and then red square and green
square so you can see how simple it is
to just serialize some data let's go
ahead and add in the rest of the
components
so as i mentioned i've already done this
before um during the live stream
which you can find on twitter tv such as
the journal or on patreon
if you want to watch the uh the rerun
we'll say the recorded version
um but over here if i paste in the rest
of this code let's kind of go through it
so it's really simple obviously it's the
same thing
so for the transform component we
obviously uh output the transform
component as a key
then we begin the map we get the
transform component and then we just
output everything the transform
component is
so it's a translation rotation scale we
simply just output that as translation
value rotation and the value and the
scale and the value
now you'll notice this isn't working
because uh we
actually need to to add an overload for
this operator
to take in a vec3 because this is a vec3
and it's a glm type and
yaml cpp the library doesn't actually
come with
operators for glm understandably because
it's a different library
it comes with a lot of operators for
default types but not for this
then we have the camera component this
is like the big juicy one there's a lot
of stuff here
so there's actually kind of two things
in this camera component there's an
actual class
called scene camera which contains a
whole bunch of data that we need to
serialize
and then there's also primary and fixed
aspect ratio
so what i've done is i've actually
instead of just outputting them as key
and values i will actually begin a map
inside
this map which is the camera class so
the camera class stuff is under its own
kind of section and then there's like
projection type and everything here
and of course this projection type which
is actually an enum
right i'm just casting it to an int so
that it
gets serialized um and that's it
that's the camera component sprite
render component same kind of thing
we're just outputting the color because
really all it is is a color
once we have textures and stuff and
assets we'll probably serialize assets
by their
their ids and their goods um and we'll
cross that bridge obviously when we get
there
that's it so these obviously don't work
so how do we make them work
well we need to overload the uh
the i guess bit shift left operators um
so i do that by just going
to the top of the file and pasting these
two in one for the vector3 one for the
vect4
really simple we basically just add the
operator with whatever type we want
and then we uh in this case i'm using
flow which basically means that instead
of outputting it as like a key
value thing for x y you know z and
everything like that
it's going to actually output them like
this
right for a vector or like this for a
vector3 which obviously is just going to
take up one line it's going to look a
lot nicer that's called flow
so i'm doing that and then we have the
begin and end sequence that's it
really simple and now obviously this
works so we're running the exact same
code again now
and opening this we now have a fully
serialized scene
how simple was that i mean i know i
coped and paid i copied and pasted like
all of the code but it is really simple
right
um so yeah
uh really really simple okay and then we
have everything that we need here
obviously
so if we go through this loosely just so
we see what's here we have a
tag component obviously the transform as
a flow that's why you see it like this
camera component with everything
serialized um
and then we have our camera a which is
in fact our primary camera so
it's set to true i think uh yeah we have
all the details here and then
um our sprite renderer with our kind of
red color which is our red square
really really really simple okay
and now finally um to deserialize this
um we need to basically do the reverse
of this it's also really easy to
deserialize
uh and i i will also copy and paste the
code but i'll take you guys
through it in the same kind of fashion
just increment and
by the way let me know what you think of
this format where i'm incrementally like
copying and pasting code
um obviously for people who are regulars
on twitch they see me go through this
for hours and type it out and work out
what it's going to be in the first place
so they might be fine with it but for
those of you who are exclusively
watching this series on youtube
let me know what you think and if this
is like i mean i imagine this is pretty
easy to understand i mean i'm going
through all the code and not copying
200 lines all at once but if there's any
problems let me know
obviously this series this series is for
you it's not for me
um i i know how to do this
uh okay so um these serialize
so the first step is going to be and
i'll actually i've added some logging
code here as well just so that we can
keep an eye on what's going on
but we basically open up an input file
stream and then into a string stream
i'm passing in the buffer from the uh
file stream
this is just the complete buffer of all
the all the text
um and then i'm passing in this string
from there
into yaml load which is the animal cbp
library the
function that actually will contain all
the data now and then then we have a
series of nodes
so if the scene node is not present um
then
i'm just return false because it has to
be in the wrong format because we have
to have a scene node that's kind of
that's what all this is really right if
there needs to be a scene node and if
there's no scene node then what is going
on it's not the right
format and then what we're going to do
is actually get the scene name
which is what we see here and then we
need to get the
next node which is going to be our
entities node so the way that we
retrieve a node which is just going to
be a yaml node i'm just using auto here
right
but we basically go to this this is the
root node
and then that node is going to have a
node called entities and you can tell
because here it is it's on the root it's
not
like a child of any other existing nodes
and it's called entities
so under the entities node we can now
check to see if that node is present
and if it is then we have entities that
we need to deserialize so that's what we
do next
so how do we loop through all of this
pretty simple we just do four
auto entity in entities
and now we have each entity node here
so from here to here basically we have
access to entity tag component and
transform component camera component and
we can just simply get them
by just being like hey entity you know
camera component
is that present and if it's present then
well we can do something with it and
that's going to be our strategy
really really simple and also really
kind of um error proof right like as in
if the node is not present we don't
deserialize it so it's not like it
expects something to be present it's
very very flexible so the first thing
we'll do is try and get the id
um the id obviously and i'll copy both
this and
i guess the tag component as well but um
the id is a to do thing at the moment
this would be the universal unique
identifier the uuid
we don't have one at the moment it's
just serialized as this blob
but i do wanna where is the blob here's
the blob
but i do want to already kind of just
create a place for it because that's
important
um and then uh
[Music]
so then we'll try and retrieve the tag
component so we'll get the tag component
if it's present
we'll get the tag as a string and now
we've got a name
for our entity which is pretty exciting
okay so next we probably need to
actually create an entity the whole
point of this is now we're
deserializing a bunch of entities we
need to add them to our scene
same way as we looped through all of the
existing entities by using um
the uh registry like each function here
right
with the entity id over here we need to
actually create entities so how do we do
that
we're going to make an entity called
deserialized
entity and set it equal to mseen
create entity and then the name
obviously now that we have a name that's
why we want to do this first
we can create an entity with that name
now
eventually we probably also pass in the
uuid and do like create an entity
uh you know with uuid or something like
that um
but we don't have one we don't have the
function yet and we don't really have
ids so
we're not gonna we're gonna worry about
that just yet
so the uh next step is gonna be the
transform component i'll just copy and
paste it
to show an example of a transform
component happening uh
really simple we just get the transform
component same as the tag component if
it's present
then uh let's uh let's actually
set the values now in this case we're
doing get component because
entities always have transforms we can
assume that it's present
because when we create an entity we also
add a transform component to it right
that's what happens here
for all of the other components though
instead of get we'll have to do add
because they're not going to be present
it's a brand new entity
we could write a function called get or
create component or get or add component
so what that would do is obviously just
in here it would just check to see hey
does it have a component if so return
get component
otherwise return add component easy
um translation rotation scale we
deserialize them now
i think we're going to need if we try
and compile this i think it's not going
work
um because uh there needs to be if you
read this properly there needs to be a
decode function
for each of these types so i've already
done that and this is from hazel dev as
well
but basically what i've done is i've
done this for just vec3 and vect4 it
looks like
inside this but this needs to be inside
the yaml namespace and i've just added
these conversion functions
so encode and decode so this will
actually go through
these custom types such as a vec3 and
actually either push back everything it
needs into the node
into the node for encoding or retrieve
the primitive types from it
right so each so this is like the result
that we're populating here
and then we're just going to basically
get node 0 1 and 2 out of the sequence
that we've previously encoded here
0 1 and 2 out of the sequence which is
essentially an array
that's in like a flow format but that's
irrelevant and it's going to actually
set the vect 3 to those values
so just adding some decentralization and
civilization code for all of these
custom types
very simple and now that should work
okay
um so the last step uh is basically the
rest of the components
inside these serialized so we've
obviously just added the transform one
which is over here
uh pretty straightforward i think again
we're just getting the component setting
the fields really easy
and then camera component and then the
sprite renderer component i'll do them
both in one go
this is exactly the same as what we had
before right
uh with the camera we just add a
component instead of get it because it's
not going to have a camera by default
and this is obviously only if it's
present inside the yaml file
so if it is present we're just going to
get the projection type
which will be you know so we're inside
camera now and then we're going to get
the projection type
because we're inside the camera node
here we'll get it as an ant but then
we'll cast it to our enum class
and that will of course set it to
whatever it needs to be now we do we
will have to fix up some stuff here
because this won't work
as expected potentially and has some
bugs with
the camera stuff because of our camera
code not because of the serialization
um because when we actually set the
projection type for a new scene it
recalculates the projection
which relies on the view the aspect
ratio being set from the viewport size
but the viewport size is well
zero by zero because it's a new scene
and it may not have had its viewport
size
set by im gui kind of panel code just
yet
so we need to make sure that we catch
that case as well um
anyway very straightforward just right
around the component distributize it as
a vector
and then set it into the component when
we add the component really easy
i don't know why that code is there i
must have copied and pasted the
transform component where i was writing
it
all right um
so next step uh
if this all succeeds and we're not like
returning false or whatever we'll
obviously return true
and then um that's i think that's
it to be honest so now what we should be
able to do
is uh let's just
get rid of we should be able to
deserialize our scene so if we just
surround all of this by an if zero
right i mean we're not doing the script
the script stuff yeah we'll talk about
that
another day um because it's like native
script stuff so it has to be handled a
bit differently
but all of this red square stuff that we
used to create if we just
um let's not serialize anything so we
don't override it
but let's just launch this we should get
just a blank empty project
there we go right now if we actually do
d serialize
we should hopefully see everything the
camera stuff might not work we'll see
how that works out
oh it did okay there we go so we've got
our scene you can see our digitalization
code worked and everything is in the
right place
um so yeah that's that's that
um so what we can do to test this out a
little bit better and i will
uh next episode we'll actually properly
write this stuff
so for now i'm going to keep it really
loose but next time we'll
had we'll have like open file save file
dialogues and stuff
we'll do that in the next episode um but
what i'll do for now
is maybe uh maybe
maybe just under this uh menu bar we
might as well do it here so we have the
file menu
let's add two more things here i won't
call them save and load or save and open
for now
i'll call them serializations because
that's literally as simple as it's going
to be
um so serialize and then deserialize
okay and it's just going to be
hard-coded to that one path keep stuff
really simple so again
really easy to construct this stuff
right so inside
deserialize i will just call this code
and then over here
a simple construction we'll just call
serialize
really really simple that's the whole
point
okay so blank scene file deserialize
got a perfect scene let's maybe move
this uh
green square out of the way so we can
see our red square as well
and then i'll serialize this and then
i'll deserialize it
oh this is one one more thing we have to
do but this is more um
this isn't really uh the serializer's
fault it's the editor layers fault
but if we open this now and we
deserialize it we should see the two
squares in their
different positions now at the moment if
we do serialize many times it's going to
keep adding
everything into the same scene right so
now if we move the green square you'll
see there's another green square
and that's because obviously we're not
actually making a new scene we're just
serializing into an existing scene
so you would fix that by actually making
a new scene but then when you do that
you have to reset the context and as i
mentioned there's going to be some
problems with the camera
because if you look at
this code over here well as soon as we
deserialize it's going to want to set
the camera projection
but it can't do that just yet because
the camera projection is dependent on
the um where is that code
it's dependent on this viewport code
stuff the active scene on viewport
resize code that hasn't run yet so we'll
run into some problems there
but anyway for the most part you can see
we can now launch
this and actually deserialize an
existing scene
which is pretty cool and not really that
much work
okay so that is the end of this episode
i hope you guys enjoyed if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button and also help support the series
by going to patreon.com the channel
you'll get access to all the past
recorded live streams as well as
dev which is where this code has existed
for like the last year
or half year or whatever um because
obviously we've been saving scenes there
for a while and that's where
everything's kind of
coming across too but thank you guys for
watching uh next time as i mentioned
we're gonna actually add a proper
like save and load um save and open file
dialogue and
all that stuff so that we can actually
save this to a custom path and load a
custom file and not have to just always
obviously read to and write from
write to and read from the
example.hazelfather we're doing here
thank you guys for watching i'll see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you